as we've seen in bakwet and mariopol
what Russia cannot take it will seek to
destroy
they want to do the same to Ukraine's
economy
and the scale of the challenge is real
the war brought a 29 fall in Ukraine's
GDP last year
but just look
at the streets of Kiev despite the
threat of attack people are getting on
with their lives and getting on with
business
president zielinski's government is
determined to drive reforms to become
more open more transparent and ready for
investment
this is a vibrant Dynamic creative
European country that refuses to be
subdued
so together with our allies we will
maintain our support for Ukraine's
defense and for the counter-offensive
we will stand with Ukraine for as long
as it takes for them to continue and to
win this war
we'll also stand with them as they win
the peace
and harness all of that Ingenuity and
Defiance to build the future that they
deserve
the question for us today
is what can we do to support this
to Fast Track recovery and help Ukraine
unleash its potential
it's clear Russia must pay for the
destruction that they've inflicted
so we're working with allies to explore
lawful routes to use Russian assets
and on Monday we publish new legislation
to allow us to keep sanctions in place
until Russia pays up
but beyond that we must bring to bear a
partnership of governments International
financial institutions and Business
Leaders all of us here today to make
this happen
the British government will continue to
play its full part and I'm proud that
today we're announcing a multi-year
commitment to support Ukraine's economy
over three years we will provide loan
guarantees worth three billion dollars
we're also launching a new UK Ukraine
Tech bridge to Foster investment and
talent along with support for green
energy and more all part of a vast
Collective effort from allies and
partners around the world
including significant new support from
the EU which is also being announced
this week